les couleurs de la ville ont terni un
peu aussi puissant à long terme je pense
que c'est quelque chose que je vois
toujours trouvé difficile la vie de
sarah maude brouillard a été bien terne
ces derniers mois la professionnelle de
la santé a contracté la coved 19 en mars
dernier j'avais pratiquement rien
jusqu'au jour j'ai complètement perdu
leurs deux recrues goût et de façon très
brutale
quatre mois plus tard le goût et
l'odorat de sarah maude ne sont toujours
pas revenu à la normale
la femme de 27 ans à plusieurs autres
symptômes qui perdure je tolère plus du
tout l'alcool il ya ce j'ai encore des
difficultés respiratoires je suis plus
essoufflé c'est moi j'étais une grande
sportive pas l'habitude d'arrêter sous
la montée des marches j'ai moins
d'énergie dérangeant parce que c'est
juste l'odorat le lait fait pas sentir
fait que la semaine dernière j'ai laissé
la bonbonne de propane ouverte barbecue
moi j'ai jamais sentie jusqu'à si
quelqu'un passe qui est un peu le gaz
est ouvert c'est dangereux c'est banal
mais ça aurait pu être dangereux
dans mon cas c'est vraiment encore une
fois la perte de goût et la terre de
doro à quelques kilomètres de là mathieu
durand vit la même situation
quatre mois après avoir été infecté il
en ressent toujours les effets à ne
jamais quelque chose qui va durer aussi
longtemps
puis qui peut être effectivement
perturbant pour au niveau physique plus
ou moins que ça fait pas mal mais
vraiment au niveau du moral
je pense que c'est non on s'attend
jamais à se serrer un mode et mathieu
espère sensibiliser les jeunes avec
leurs témoignages ils sont de plus en
plus nombreux à avoir été infectés au
cours des dernières semaines
ça me dérange de voir que des gens qui
disent bien même si je laisse pas grave
si l'irruption j'entends souvent des
gens qui existe derrière des correct ça
va être juste
bruce welch perec physiquement jeu
correct et tout et tout est correct mais
c'est jusqu'à sachant qu'il ya des
jeunes que savard dérange pas c'est
quand même être prenez les mêmes
conséquences sont partir de 2 voulait
laisser de retrouver une normalité que
je connaissais avant que vont vivre les
séquelles que que j'ai en ce moment plus
à part que ça reste comme ça je pense
que je suis c'est assez suffisant pour
que les jeunes
puis c'est à lui me disait mais gardons
va le porter une vaste un message
souvent répété par la santé publique ici
mario bérubé radio canada